pour moi aujourd'hui la raison
essentielle qui puisse pousser quelqu'un
à faire de la musique c'est de créer de
vraies valeurs
le saxophoniste est compositeur one
shorthair au Ramier pour un unique
récital après avoir joué avec arbre qui
Mike Davis il a choisi de former son
propre ensemble en fin d'après-midi il
était 18h30 il découvrait la scène où
les Toulousains vont l'applaudir ce soir
reportage de Dominique Deluze et de
Gérard nerand
[Musique]
je n'ai
plus besoin souffle en substance
winchorter aujourd'hui avec son nouveau
quintet il est vrai que pendant 30 ans
tout brillant compositeur qu'il était
winchorter à quelque peu souffert
d'avoir joué à l'ombre d'art black et de
Miles Davis et puis ensuite d'avoir été
phagocyté par le groupe de jazz rock
water report maintenant sur de son art
il ne pêche plus par excès de modestie
serein Shorter et les siens rejoignent
une voie plus jazzy et retrouve les
chemins de la création
[Musique]
pour moi aujourd'hui la raison
essentielle qui puisse pousser quelqu'un
à faire de la musique c'est de créer de
vraies valeurs celle qui aide les autres
avis vivre exactement comme par exemple
un médecin qui part sa science facilite
la vie des gens
je suis un peu comme un postier qui
voudrait devenir un grand postier ni
plus ni moins
[Musique]
son jazz aujourd'hui c'est celui de tous
les mélanges et ceci dans tous les sens
il a confié rythme et percussions à deux
talentueuses jeunes filles qui apportent
une nouvelle sensibilité rendez-vous
donc avec le quintet de Wayne Shorter ce
soir à 21h à la salle des ramiers à
Toulouse
[Musique]